Joel clack but to see the leader last
two years yes you're right but it's good
it's good to be gently you broke him to
me gently all those years yeah listen I
thought that they had a good shot this
year and I was even wrong about that
partly because of last night's 15th pick
you know because he was brilliant that I
know and it was funny last night with
David Shaw talking about how brilliant
he doing Haskins was in the Maryland
game yes we were talking about the fact
that he's gonna play a lot in Maryland
but Virginia yeah I'm gonna be playing
in the mid-atlantic where he played his
high school ball and I told him I'm like
thanks for bringing up the Maryland game
and not the game after that game yeah
exactly well I mean he was he was
actually committed to mayor Linda and
and and then there were some things that
happened where all the sudden Ohio State
had a spot open up and then he committed
to Ohio State after that but real quick
I want to go back to that because you
bring up let's start with Dwayne asking
if you got over mind oh please we
haven't really hit it to him here's why
I'm surprised he fell is because for me
trajectory of a player has a big value
proposition if I'm gonna value a kid I
don't want if you've played for three
years there's a good chance you're
probably just gonna get a little bit
better if you've played for one year and
I'm seeing growth throughout the year I
can at least project out that you're
gonna have a pretty substantial growth
pattern for the first two three years of
your NFL career well that's exactly what
I saw from Dwayne Haskins I saw him as
the backup when he came in down six in
the big house he leads them back to
victory and in a really brilliant second
half after JT Barrett got injured then
he's the starting quarterback and their
team kind of hits this lull when they
lose nick Bosa to the injury and then
all the sudden Urban Meyer had a
conversation with him before that
Maryland game that you were talking
about and he brought up Kobe Bryant and
how Kobe Bryant was assertive both
vocally and physically as the leader and
then Dwayne took that to heart and rich
in that game against Maryland rushes for
three touchdowns really put the Buckeyes
on his back and willed them to victory
and then there was no quarterback in the
country even Cuyler Murray to Otunga by
Aloha no quarterback in the country
played better over his last four games
than Dwayne Haskins he was the best
quarterback of the I would call the top
two
around guys in this draft when it comes
to playing against top 25 defenses in
college and yards per play his
statistics were through the roof so I'm
shocked that he fell to Washington but
Washington has got to be elated at the
value at 15 and a good a good kid to
young who knows the area and and the the
connections with Kevin O'Connell right
from obviously formerly uh you know of
the Jets staff and he goes the 49ers he
was under Ryan de when Ryan de was with
the 49 so that makes sense right there
and now also twice a year he'll be going
against the Giants team who went in
another direction and that was one of
the videos tonight that that went viral
last night that went viral was him
looking on his phone when Daniel Jones
was named and just sort of like shaking
his head quick shake of the heads the
quick shake of the head I did a little
more than that I was a little more than
a shake of the head oh my goodness I
thought that the New York Giants had
disastrous night last night disastrous
and I think it might take years to
recover okay yeah there's no doubt about
you cannot miss when you've got the
opportunity to have two first-round
picks when you're drafting quarterbacks
wire why are the Denver Broncos in the
state that they are because they've
missed on quarterbacks in the first
round they had to go get Peyton Manning
he recovered them brought him a Super
Bowl and Super Bowl 50 but they're not
what they have been historically because
they have missed on first-round
quarterbacks
I hope Daniel Jones has a lot of success
for Giants fans sakes for his sake but
the fact of the matter is every single
one of the Giants three picks last night
they overvalued that player by at a
minimum 10 spots that is that's a
disaster just from a value proposition
they could have gotten a Pro Bowl
defensive player next year at six gotten
Daniel Jones at 17 gotten Dexter
Lawrence at 37 tonight because Lawrence
would have still been available and they
didn't need to trade up to get a corner
because everybody in the league had
corners rated differently if you asked
20 general managers in the league rate
the top five corners you're gonna get 25
or 20 different top fives so all of a
sudden they trade up to get a listen
like DeAndre Baker he's a he's a really
good player he was overvalued at that
spot so I don't know what Dave gentlemen
is doing he clearly you know stuck to
his board but I think ultimately it's
gonna bite him in the future
okay well I'll give you the flip side of
that Greg Simon okay
I heard the Rams love DeAndre Baker to
the point when they traded out right
away
yeah when Baker went off the board yeah
because the Giants traded up before him
because someone was gonna take right so
cuz the rent I think the Rams would have
jumped on him at 30 at 31 so there's
that obviously Dexter Lawrence's if you
say he would have been available tonight
I mean there was a run on defensive
tackles just an absolute flat-out
Clemson defense they were worried about
the Chargers you know down a little bit
lower they were worried about Tennessee
those two teams ended up taking
defensive tackles like one the you know
the troubled referee Jeffrey Simmons
from Mississippi State right Chargers
took Jerry Tillery so that's so I
thought on that 100% then in in the 16
years that I've done this now and with
the NFL Network and 15 with just the
draft alone all I hear from evaluators
and I'm sure you would agree with this
if you love the quarterback it doesn't
matter where you take you take him yeah
and and you heard what gentleman said he
he's he had him in hello at the at the
Senior Bowl Cole I think it's the safe
pick you know I talked about it mattered
so and the college game just understands
he in the NFL the margin between average
players and great players is very small
very small average teams and great teams
very small everything's a 1-1 possession
game right I mean everything's kind of
the same the NFL it is the exact
opposite in the college game you can put
up monster numbers against terrible
teams and so I always separate out what
do you do against quality opponents you
know what do you do when it's a like
opponent when things are difficult
unless you so that's why I brought up
the stat about Dewayne Haskins against
top 25 yards per play defenses he played
five of those games last year he was 62%
around 300 yards 15 touchdowns one
interception best of anybody in the in
the top two rounds as far as
quarterbacks go meanwhile Daniel
Jones was last on that list of any of
the quarterbacks that I had rated for
the top two rounds 59% barely 230 yards
five touchdowns three interceptions with
a Rainey just above a hundred so for me
that matters now you can also say
Haskins had a better supporting cast and
I totally agree I agree with that right
and I hope Daniel Jones has a lot of
success but man it just felt like a
giant reach for me based on what was
happening at the college level in
particular against quality of phone so
then who did you like last night that
value in that pick like boy that's a
great spot right there when it would it
be what I think Jen Allen would have
been off the board right in Jacksonville
and input I thought Josh Allen was the
pick I thought that Oliver would have
been a terrific pick for the giant - yes
you know what I feel about him man yeah
you know Steeler fans are fired
they should be pop right now they had
such a clear plan last night they had
two guys targeted Devon white or Devon
Bush I believe that they were building
for their division there's some strong
running games in that division you got
the running backs for Cleveland you got
a little more Jackson yeah I mean you've
got to have a linebacker that can cover
space tackle well and it's difficult
always to talk about the football
ramifications of the Ryan shazier
internet of how significant the injury
was yeah but if we can put that aside
and just talk about how it affected the
defense it immeasurably and Devon Bush
could return that sideline to sideline
domination the to that defense right
there and fits with city's fan bases and
coaching staff right that one felt like
an immediate fit his emotional kind of
playing mentality I think fits in
Pittsburgh they're gonna love him he's
gonna get that stadium going when he
walks out there I know I mean so and I
know I'm biased I know I'm biased so
would win a [ __ ] who's from the area
it's true he's available tonight he is
available tonight he's still out there
tonight I don't know again they've been
creating John Brown's defy don't know
man I mean
it kind of worked for much of the time
rather than anything else and I love
Christian Wilkins obviously a 13-2 miles
a pic that was a good one also and then
a denver getting noah Fant at 20 after
moving down from 10 was it nice with
some extra pics you know so yeah I like
that one as well and I want to go back
to Wilkins Oh for if if Miami I think
Miami might be the only trade suitor for
Rosen at this point but if you're
sitting there from their perspective if
they could walk out of this draft having
not given a first rounder for Josh Rosen
maybe even getting away with giving a
late second or even next year second and
they got Christian Wilkins they would
have to be thrilled paying Josh Rosen
six million over three years
you get Wilkins you had all of a sudden
have to look at Miami boy you'd say
clearly there they are on that long road
exactly what the content the contract
for their coach all of those things
Miami could after tonight be looking
really good Joel clad here on the Rich
Eisen show I just don't see anybody
coughing that type of value for rosin up
and it has nothing to do with Rosen's
ability there's no reason to give up a
to this year next year a three even
right now because the Cardinals what are
they gonna do they're really gonna have
two young kids like that they've insane
well the kid that's why there's no
market I thought that he should have
been traded maybe even before free
agency yeah you know I thought that that
that's when you were gonna get the most
value for Josh Rose right there they did
have a couple of offers of firm seconds
and they didn't pick him they wanted a
first well the only danger in that and
we talked about putting headsets on is
that maari's baseball yes was always the
if that even even hours before they made
him the first overall selection the
highest honor you could give a college
athlete is your first overall in the NFL
Draft they're still trying to figure out
language the just in case yes so you
can't pull the trigger on something in
February you know so here's the rock and
a hard place they were in if you did
pull the trigger in February
now Murray's got you over a barrel
and I mean he can he can demand whatever
he wants because you are totally up a
creek without a paddle if you don't make
the move in February and you wait until
last night and you hope that the market
materializes after you make the pick and
it doesn't you're dead there's that's
all gone it's gone it's evaporated I
think this is exactly what's happened
before I let you go what do you think
what do you think we're seeing tonight
run on defensive backs what do you think
happened corners you know I think we're
gonna see a lot of corners in particular
in this second round I think we're gonna
see a lot of wide receivers exactly what
we didn't see in the first round right
which was those skilled position players
we had Marquis Brown and Nikhil Harry
but I think you're gonna start to see
maybe you know five six wide receivers
gets swiped off the board and then I
think that you're gonna see fairly early
you're gonna see a drew lock or a will
Grier you know because those two guys
were evaluated pretty high but there
were some questions but at this point
now you feel like it's good value for
the long run maybe a backup role for the
first couple of years and a long-term
starter for you so I think those skilled
position players on offense and skill
position players on defense I think
we're going to see a pretty good run all
right since we've last one since we've
been questioning Steve comms acumen
let's do him a solid would you give up a
two tonight for Rosen as opposed to bill
Grier or Locke but I would now I'm a big
believer in Rosen I would have had him
like 1a 1b with Kyler in this draft so I
was surprised that a trade didn't take
take place the contract is super
friendly
I would I would absolutely flip Arizona
because again it's the same mantra you
can say well did the Giants really make
a mistake if they really got their guy
well if Rosen you think is gonna be the
guy right doesn't give a first - I mean
who cares you know
well I love I love everything that you
do Joel I tell they every single time
and tonight's gonna be fun tonight right
the great yep you and Daniel Jeremiah me
and Charles Davis at 7:00 Eastern Time
on the NFL Network Joel cloud which does
a great job with Gus one time you're
gonna come on the show and you and I are
just gonna hear Gus stories from your
mouth that's
all I want that you know what maybe
maybe sometime in like June when we're
not when you're just chilling I would
love to I can tell you the story of how
Hollywood Brown became Hollywood Brown
it's epic okay this is this is what we
call the tease right now I know the fans
want it right it's called a tease leave
you wanting more but again maybe this
summer when the NFL haze in the bar not
yet getting on the road obviously for
college football yes it's just straight
incoming just tell me Gus story I would
love to all right at Joel Klatt on
Twitter Joel underscore clot on
Instagram tonight 7:00 Eastern Time
catch me and Joel and the rest of the
NFL Network crew at work Eddie George is
going to be joining us next here live in
Nashville on the Rich Eisen show for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 under red TV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app